hallo zusammen wir machen heute ein
schnelles und leckeres veganes Curry ich
selber ernähre mich gar nicht vegan
warum hast du so verwirrt geguckt weil
ich carry gesagt habe es hat Curry wir
machen jetzt Curry gut alte Curry so und
ich erinnere mich selber nicht vegan
aber natürlich gibt es auch bei mir
oftmals veganes Mittagessen und
die einzige Arbeit und das ist
eigentlich gar keine Arbeit ist das
Gemüse vorab klein zu schnibbeln und der
Rest geht ganz schnell also es ist schon
15 Minuten Rezept ich habe sogar den
Reis schon vorbereitet dann mache ich
jetzt nicht den typisch türkischen mit
den Fadennudeln sondern ganz normal Reis
ich persönlich wasche den halt immer
gerne damit die Stärke rausgewaschen
wird und der nicht mehr so klebt ich
riss die noch gerne etwas Öl an und dann
gab er einfach vor sich hin ja und ich
nehme jetzt und danach gehen wir an den
Herz
[Musik]
also zwiebeln und Knoblauch gehören
immer dazu ihr könnt auch ganz normale
helle Zwiebeln nehmen ich habe jetzt nur
die roten da das ist gar kein Problem
und an Gemüse könnt jetzt eigentlich
nehmen was ihr wollt was aber für mich
ein Muss ist sind Kichererbsen die sind
jetzt aus dem Glas bzw könnt auch aus
der Dose nehmen also auf jeden Fall aus
der Konserve die sind ja dann schon
eingeweicht und die sind dann nicht mehr
hart das heißt die könnte eigentlich
sofort verwenden und das ist halt unsere
Eiweißquelle hier im Gericht und dann
habe ich hier noch weiteres Gemüse rote
Paprika grüne Paprika und Möhren nehme
ich noch mit dazu aber es ist halt alles
super austauschbar also könnt ihr da
total variieren genau das schnibbel ich
jetzt auch noch klein und dann geht aber
an den Herd also wie gesagt
Schnippelarbeit kurz erledigen und der
Rest geht super schnell
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt hier schon etwas Öl in
meiner Pfanne erhitzt ich habe jetzt
hier die hochanfpfanne genommen weil ich
denke schon dass es so ein bisschen was
an Masse geben wird jetzt und da gebe
ich jetzt natürlich Knoblauch und
Zwiebeln vorab mit dazu dünste dazu 2
Minuten und anschließend kommt auch
schon das Gemüse mit hinein
[Musik]
so nicht wundern hier hängt mein Handy
filmen die Lichter ein bisschen was für
Instagram und für tiktok mit falls Ihr
mir da noch nicht folgt holt das gerne
nach weil da gibt es dann auch noch mal
special Rezepte die ich nur mit dem
Handy Filme und die ist dann exklusiv
Halt gibt das sind dann meistens schnell
und einfache Rezepte so ich gebe jetzt
noch also Kichererbsen habe ich ganz zum
Schluss mit dazu gegeben als Hinweis die
müssen jetzt irgendwie weich werden oder
so gib jetzt hier noch Tomaten aus der
Dose mit rein so ich habe jetzt hier
durch Zufall Cherrytomaten aus der Dose
ihr könnt auch ganz normale gehackte
Tomaten nehmen also das Rezept ist super
variabel echt easy und jetzt kommt auch
noch Kokosmilch zum Einsatz und da bitte
die ganz normale fettreiche nehmen also
jetzt nichts fettarmes könntet ihr zwar
machen aber dann schmeckt so ein
bisschen wässrig und genauso haben wir
eben dieses cremiger und leckere das
kommt jetzt noch mit rein
und dann würzen wir das Ganze und lassen
das eigentlich nur noch 10 Minuten vor
sich hin köcheln also die 5 Minuten
brauchen wir auf jeden Fall für die
Kichererbsen und noch weitere 5 Minuten
einfach damit alles so den Geschmack
annimmt aber wie gesagt wir brauchen
jetzt erstmal die Gewürze
ja komm mal rum nee
haben sie arbeitet im Nebenraum aber
sieht jetzt schon richtig lecker aus oh
ich liebe diese Farbe so und an Gewürzen
braucht ihr gar nicht viel wir brauchen
natürlich Salz Pfeffer und dann nehme
ich einfach nur noch ein Curry dazu
curry ist ja immer eine Gewürzmischung
ich nehme heute mein Bollywood Express
ihr könntet auch im Dach und Curry
nehmen der verschiedenen Wortwitz ich
liebe den und ähm genau Curry was ihr
mögt dann nehme ich noch Paprika edel
sich dazu und Kreuzkümmel Kreuzkümmel
aus dem Grund weil die Kichererbsen sind
so ein bisschen aufbläht wirken und
Kreuzkümmel wirkt da einfach immer
entgehen
[Musik]
so ich habe das jetzt zehn Minuten
köcheln lassen und das sieht wunderschön
aus also allein optisch gibt es schon
mal zehn von zehn Punkte ich würde das
jetzt zusammen mit dem Reis servieren
ihr könnt auch Joghurt dazu reichen das
mache ich auch da gebe ich einfach nur
noch ein bisschen Salz mit rein ihr
könntet auch Knoblauch mit reingehen
finde ich ja auch mal richtig lecker
Joghurt mit Knoblauch so der Reis kommt
einmal zu mir wichtig ist dass Sie den
Reis echt vorher schon ansetzt weil
sonst wartet ihr auf den Reis weil das
Gericht wirklich schnell geht ich nehme
jetzt so eine kleine Schale da kommt
jetzt man könnte auch mein Reis
anschauen wie wie locker und wie fluffig
der ist wenn ihr den vorher auswascht
damit die Stärke rausgeht ich habe jetzt
etwas Martin Reis sondern gebe ich hier
einfach in meine in meine kleine Schale
und dann kommt der umgedreht einfach auf
mein Teller dann serviere ich noch
meinen veganes Curry dazu und wenn ihr
möchtet könnt ihr dann noch gehackten
Kurier ich habe eine Sache vergessen
jetzt habe ich hier noch eine Limette
ich persönlich finde dass die schon sein
muss also die Runde schon den Geschmack
ab diese leichte Säure
Zitronen könnt ihr notfalls auch aber
besser ist wirklich eine Limette zu
nehmen und da Presse ich jetzt noch so
ein paar Tropfen in das Essen wenn ihr
es nicht da haben sollte das ist kein
Weltuntergang aber es ist es hebt
einfach noch mal offen anderes Level
würde ich mal behaupten so einfach nur
so ein bisschen
jetzt leichte Säure dann noch mal so
dann noch mal verrühren und dann
servieren
[Musik]
so das war's auch schon mit dem
schnellen veganen Rezept wenn euch das
Rezept gefallen hat dann lasst doch
gerne ein Abo da und dann sehen wir uns
auch immer im nächsten Rezept Video und
ähm ja ansonsten viel Spaß beim
Nachkochen und bis zum nächsten Mal auf
die Sketchen tschüss
[Musik]